el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador cumplió tres años en el
cargo
entrando así en la segunda mitad de su
mandato después de un periodo marcado
entre otras cosas por sus políticas para
combatir la desigualdad de ese país
habló cuenta entonces con una
popularidad en torno al 60 por ciento
según varias encuestas pero la
inseguridad sigue siendo un desafío que
su administración no ha logrado
controlar en lo económico la inflación
del país supera el 7 por ciento la más
alta en dos décadas y en medio de este
panorama lópez obrador promueve una
revocatoria ciudadana para que las urnas
decidan si termina su mandato antes de
2024 para ello entonces le doy la
bienvenida a nuestro programa de enrique
gutiérrez márquez él es el profesor del
departamento de ciencias sociales y
políticas de la universidad
iberoamericana gracias enrique por estar
con nosotros en directo américa le
pregunta entonces el balance de estos
años que es lo que más destaca lo bueno
y lo humano lo malo ha cumplido amplio
con lo prometido en su campaña
pero en primer lugar saludarte raúl a ti
ya toda la audiencia yo te diría que si
en efecto el gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador
ha estado digamos plagados de
claroscuros en términos de los avances y
los retos que le plantea para su propia
administración y para el país esto así
es ahora una muy buena síntesis de
algunos de los indicadores importantes
en donde por supuesto destacan varios de
los retos que tiene el país y por
supuesto la administración de andrés
manuel lópez obrador en lo que respecta
por ejemplo a los temas de seguridad al
combate a la corrupción y por supuesto a
todos los elementos que plantean digamos
el asunto de los derechos humanos en
méxico pero del otro lado y tú ya lo
estabas destacando pues todo lo que
tiene que ver por ejemplo con la
recuperación del salario mínimo en
méxico que creció por lo menos en este
año en un 44 por ciento y que con el 20
por ciento que anunció ayer mismo el
presidente el observador llegará a una
recuperación del 60 por ciento
a digamos un avance interesante sumado a
todos los otros indicadores económicos
que tú señalabas con el tema de la
inflación que si bien está un punto
arriba de lo que se planteó en las metas
iniciales de la administración de lópez
obrador bueno que se mantiene en un 7
por ciento que está abajo de lo que se
espera en la propia región
latinoamericana y el otro de los
indicadores importantes tendría que ver
con control el control que se ha dado
por ejemplo con el tipo de cambio en
méxico que se mantuvo muy estable hasta
las últimas fechas con la aparición de
la nueva variante del óbito que generó
un desbalance incluso en términos
internacionales pero yo te diría me
parece que a pesar de estos claros puros
que yo señalaba en un primer momento
raúl me parece que el balance en muchos
sentidos es muy positivo porque habría
que sumarle a este casi 65 según los
datos que yo tengo y según los promedios
de varias casas encuestadoras casi 65
promedio por ciento de aprobación
promedio del presidente de lópez pues
habría que sumar las más de 55 reformas
legales que fueron basadas en el espacio
del congreso que tienen que ver con
diferentes temas que si quieres ahora
platicamos ahora enrique pero le quiero
preguntar entonces si ha sido un balance
promedio positivo porque lópez obrador
quiere pues ir a las urnas para ver si
termina su mandato o no cuál es el afán
del presidente de medirse en las urnas
mira yo creo que él lo anunció desde el
inicio de su gobierno y ha sido muy
insistente en términos de la importancia
que para él tiene el tema de la
revocación de mandato si atendemos un
poco estas cifras de preferencia o de
aprobación del presidente de la
republica posiblemente sea un ejercicio
que lo ratifique en el en el mandato y
en el espacio de la presidencia de la
república por los últimos tres años más
pero un poco lo que planteó ayer incluso
en este mensaje es un mensaje nuevo en
méxico gméxico normalmente los informes
presidenciales eran como el día del
presidente pero además eran informes
formales frente al espacio
y de hecho ya se ha hecho en méxico
estamos teniendo que acostumbrarnos a un
nuevo modelo de comunicación política y
el día de ayer en este mensaje político
que era en el zócalo de la ciudad de
mexico que se como el epicentro del
centro político o ha sido durante muchos
años ese centro político de discusión y
de presencia de las movilizaciones
sociales lo que enfatiza raúl es este
interés por institucionalizar en la
democracia en méxico mecanismos de
democracia directa que dicho sea de paso
han sido incorporados en otros países me
parece un éxito interesante y que lo que
él plantea es precisamente que es uno de
los mensajes políticos fuertes que si el
pueblo pone y el pueblo quita en frases
de una frase el presidente lópez obrador
pues tendría que hacer el pueblo por un
proceso de democracia directa que a la
mitad del camino de lo que ocurrió en su
sexenio valore o evalúe si se queda o no
en el espacio el ejercicio de poder me
parece que en latinoamérica no es un
ejercicio que podamos desdeñar digamos
fácilmente me parece como interesante lo
que plantea usted en términos de esta
evaluación que hace qué hace el pueblo
el ejercicio de los gobernantes ahora
enrique hay muchos temas de inseguridad
pandemia el télica la migración pero le
pregunto en esto en ese tiempo que le
queda estos años que le quedan al
presidente lópez obrador en que se
tendría que enfocar donde tendría que
poner en la lupa los temas más urgentes
del país
mira yo te diría que creo que es una
constante en los diferentes sistemas
políticos no quiero ser muy técnicos
pero en términos de la definición de un
sistema político por lo menos en méxico
lo que ha ocurrido es que los primeros
tres años de gobierno son años de mucha
fortaleza años en donde los propios
gobiernos pueden avanzar incluso con
muchas reformas que plantean en espacio
legislativo o iniciativas de gobierno o
políticas públicas y los últimos tres
años de gobierno
normalmente están vinculados con un
declive de estos gobiernos en esta
tradición que se ha mucho en méxico me
parece que todos estos actos que
nosotros estamos viendo apuntan como a
dos cosas importantes por un lado a un
unas elecciones que vamos a tener en
méxico en donde se van a reelegir seis
gubernaturas en el 2022 y las elecciones
del 2024 en donde se renovará la
presidencia de la república la cámara de
senadores y la cámara diputados pero el
presidente también ha sido muy enfático
en cuáles son los temas que él tiene
pendientes en términos formales de la
agenda legislativa una reforma
político-electoral
una nueva reforma un nuevo impulso de la
reforma eléctrica o de hidrocarburos en
este caso energética y consolidar el
tema de la guardia nacional y por
supuesto uno de los grandes temas que
planteó en su momento que fue la
consolidación de este proceso de
revocación de mandato y yo te diría que
estructuralmente en efecto y creo que lo
señalas bien hay muchos otros temas que
están vinculados con el asunto del
crecimiento de la pobreza en méxico no
nada más por condiciones internas sino
por condiciones externas y por una
pandemia global el tema de la seguridad
es un asunto estructural que tanto en
méxico como en colombia y en otros
países de américa latina'
desafortunadamente pues son el pan de
cada día de nuestras sociedades y que
sin duda en estos claroscuros y en este
balance es un elemento que queda como
una agenda pendiente para el presidente
en méxico pero yo diría para varios
países de la región latinoamericana